take me out to the ballgame take me out
with the class buy me some peanuts and
cracker jack I don't care if I never get
back let me rule will root for the home
team if they don't win it's a shame i am
nick gillespie of reason TV this is a
great time of year if you're a sports
fan you've got the NBA Playoffs going on
you've got the NHL playoffs going on and
baseball season is just underway nobody
this year seems more excited than fans
of the Washington Nationals we decided
to go down and see how they like their
new stadium on opening day I love it I
love it yeah it's great it's going to be
great for the community tired of going
to Baltimore and sinners senators were
gone and gnats are back nice that's
pretty sweet pretty sweet yeah it's good
stadiums it's nice such a beautiful
stadium didn't exactly come cheap the
taxpayers kicked in over six hundred
million dollars in order to pay for this
and along with that came big promises of
economic development as you can see
there's old bunch of development going
on here renovations great this was a
very underdeveloped area before they
tore down most the projects new
buildings are going up neighborhoods are
getting safer it'll increase the tax
base it brings one money into the
stadium and be good for everybody there
is no evidence that those subsidies do
what they claim to do who's that party
pooper his name is Dennis coats he's an
economist at University of Maryland
Baltimore County he and a colleague did
a study about the way in which
professional sports franchises have an
impact economically on cities the
overall impact was negative that in fact
it wasn't that having these sports
variables caused income to be higher it
was that income tended to be lower and
it was lower by about forty dollars per
year well there's no question that
there's a lot of activity around every
sports stadium so why doesn't it
actually increase any kind of revenue
they don't make any money they just
generate new spending in one
location by taking it from another
that's not benefit that the society
that's just the benefit to the people
who got the money given to them at a
cost of the money taken from someone
else don't expect politicians edifice
complex to go away any time soon in fact
the major soccer team here DC United is
already pushing for its own heavily
subsidized stadium and they'll probably
almost certainly get it but even if the
DC Nationals make it all the way to the
World Series this year there's no
question that taxpayers have struck out
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie